hello everyone I'm Ilana and I'm very
very very bad at platformers if there
are things you should know about me as a
gamer it is one terrible at platform is
and two is that I don't play audiences
because I don't enjoy them as much as
anything else played a bunch of Age of
Empires as a kid but otherwise that's
one genre that I'm just completely
lacking so here's the thing even though
I'm hot trash platformers I still enjoy
them I figured because people enjoyed
watching me suffer through Crash
Bandicoot so much that I would play some
Super Mario maker
okay I'm gonna start with escape from
the skull palace this one was made by a
very good friend of mine Billy Shipley
who works at pub G full CLE is brothe
pretty freaking doofus okay this all
seems fine pretty chill frankly okay
okay that needs a key we don't have one
well we can get to this door now I don't
know if this is where I meant to go
though are you kidding
is this possible okay okay
[ __ ] I didn't know that was this dumb
that was dumb also don't feel like I
want anything all right no [ __ ]
distance to the front this yeah I'm
gonna die there's too many of them now
ok the next [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok well oh forgot about that
yep he definitely shows up there that's
the thing that I forgot happens great
love it [ __ ] jump on him press X [ __ ]
you that was [ __ ] rude I didn't ask
for that I didn't deserve that at all
you son of a [ __ ] pick me pick you up
note also didn't pick him up
ok x8 boom didn't walk anyway throw hyah
I guess
that [ __ ] would've worked though
right alright 15 tries the the charm
you can just get [ __ ] get out of here
I don't want you I don't need you in my
life you I do need their gonna X with an
eighth-note runway and I jumped off the
edge I thought I was gonna do some pro
game a strat and I did not wait till one
comes over this way it's a bad idea to
let this get out of hand I know it is ok
boom got it
yes holy [ __ ] I got it I'm nervous oh
the pressure oh [ __ ]
oh God oh this okay I didn't I had a
second to look at it and be like what am
I going to do next
no he's gone okay good oh he hit me love
it okay that's he's gonna explode that's
not good that [ __ ] oh yes boy oh [ __ ] I
completely forgot that I have to Cooper
madness you say alright it's my little
64 Mario I do feel more comfortable with
him this all seems very pleasant in
comparison thus far yeah yeah of course
that would work
feeling great this is so uplifting come
into that loss level what do I care
about any of you bunch of punks
cow it's all of you okay oh well that's
fine I don't really need that that might
be one of these boxes that I do need
though your your Punk I don't want I
don't want anything to do with you get
out of here what are you that would have
been great actually that would have
helped me a ton I would have loved to
have had that give me that give me that
mmm that's unfortunate cuz I needed that
didn't I lost time this next parts gonna
be a bit tough without it I think I can
probably do it okay yeah no I can do
this fine jump on all of you one by one
I needed that no I Lana had it okay I
need to get the stall and then get get
the the mushroom and then this is all
gonna be a goddamn breeze well that's
cool okay I think I see what you want me
to do you want me to okay okay hmm no
runway ah excellent
love it love it just take one hit yes
[ __ ] oh oh I did it that was a very
anticlimactic ending we passed a level
yeah 28 percent easy not even gonna die
it's probably gonna be a flawless finish
okay
what no that's gonna hurt me oh we
didn't I'm suspicious
Ilana that was your own fault this is
this is I'm unsettled by how simple this
seems sorry dry bones no [ __ ] you
Ilana what are you you why did you press
B that's the wrong button you know that
that's the wrong button
at that time you just jumped up you just
walked off you just walked right off you
you thought that you hit B but you
didn't it didn't happen
you just [ __ ] walked off the ledge
you stupid piece of [ __ ] running into
dry bones it's fine who cares whatever
it's not like
huge deal noop if we just keep running
all right that's okay
mmm 0.5 - I love it okay I do want to
try logics one even if I know me to fail
on it just cuz I'm curious so that's all
right 2.8 it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen I'm sorry what what why
would you do that
Jesus okay okay yeah let's clear them
all out kill them all
who needs two totals anyway that's what
I always say more straws what is wrong
with you I can't make that oh I almost
made it okay maybe I can make it okay
Jesus
damn damn Oh Alana okay okay I can do
that then one jump sure sure if you felt
you were supposed to jump on you fell I
said I specifically said jump idiot
you [ __ ] prick again oh come on baby
[ __ ] jump jump
oh oh oh you had it though you had it go
nope too late jump too late [ __ ] run
[ __ ] run oh [ __ ] yes woman jump jump no
no no I should have jumped on him I felt
really funny Preston well I guess I did
not press it okay okay Dam dam dam dam
pressure is on
boom nope [ __ ]
oh it's so easy to fail just kill me
just kill me
all right all right we moving on
I'm sorry logic please don't be
disappointed in me
I did like it though I'll give you a
like but I can't I can't keep doing this
to myself
everybody take a water break I'm gonna
try this whatever this [ __ ] office
all is ten times that's I mean that's
cool that's a cool thing that you put in
this then I'm in - all right oh I
panicked no new and then up no [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you you know how to do this woman okay
just fellas
cuz I tried to run okay [ __ ] alright
and then we're gonna tap oh not [ __ ]
[ __ ] Everest B instead of what okay [ __ ]
so I be be up like if my neighbors can
hear me think I think I sound insane
[ __ ] get in the pipe
get in the [ __ ] pipe Mario B again
boom there we go Oh didn't of course
that was going to happen I didn't think
about it I didn't consider that it would
do that so I wasn't prepared come on
[ __ ] dog so I have to hit the bullet
bill and then jump where these levels
are really rude
all right it's done 0.01 percent
completion rate you know boys this is
the one I'm gonna get
I think this is it yeah there's no way I
could fail at this cuz I am better than
everyone else at this game where am I
supposed to go where do I even stop if I
can just stop hitting it Ilana you just
jumped you know to jump soon you idiot
you know you can okay from there slide
down oh the fire got me okay if we do
this and then nope nope that's not what
I wanted whoever makes these levels is
just a prick okay maybe I need to try to
slide again come back and slide in it oh
this is gonna suck not intentionally the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was my [ __ ] prick
Leeson cashed up though
[ __ ] your hitbox yecch rubbish wasn't
even pixels one even colliding Oh
antennas a bunch of fake gamers [ __ ] you
just tell me what you want what do you
want me to do what's what's the EMA the
person who made this needs to be jailed
actually okay so what then
right so if I get it what do you what am
I supposed to do here what
Oh prick your prick you're a piece of
[ __ ] nobody likes you and you are not
worth my anger so cuz you suck hole well
degrees Oh what the [ __ ] what uh they're
they're everywhere this is gonna be so
ridiculous there is no way no I'm out
I'm out
it's not it's not happening for me this
this is horseshit you're you sadistic
this is sadistic I'm not